Justin Fox Business and Economics
columnist at Time magazine
I mean the basic the basis of the theory
is just that wall street knows what it's
doing that prices move on stock markets
in particular but financial markets in
general for a good reason because all
these investors and speculators are
bringing all this information in an
opinion to bear and therefore delivering
the best possible assessment of what a
particular stock or bond or whatever
else is worth and I mean part of the
attraction of it is at some level it's
at least partly true stock markets
aren't they're not completely driven by
noise they're not completely driven by a
rationality if they were I think we
would have decided to get rid of them at
this point although I guess a lot of
people make money off them so you never
know but but still there there's some
element of rationality and reflection of
fundamentals going on in market behavior
so that's one reason why it's attractive
the other reason why it's attractive and
especially the version of it that was
born or reborn in the 1960s and really
became incredibly influential in the 70s
and 80s and 90s is it just makes life so
much more simpler if you simply just go
from the starting point that financial
market prices are right then you can do
so many great things you can calculate
the cost of capital really easily if
you're a corporate decision maker trying
to decide whether you want to do an
investment or not you can pick out an
investment strategy that makes sense
that balances risk and reward
appropriately very easily you can
basically approach the market in this
scientific fashion that can be taught to
other people and hand it down to other
people it isn't all about gossip or
people's strange opinions it's this
scientific straightforward guide to
decision-making in and around the market
one of the fascinating things that's
going on right now is a bunch of
economist paul krugman and brad delong
among them trying to come up with a
pretty much rational explanation of
bubbles of how bubbles work and what the
what the interaction is between leverage
and bubbles and and and what causes them
and I think it I'm fascinated by it I
don't know if it will deliver any real
answers but it's just sort of this
attempt to use the fact that even people
who in their individual position as a
hedge fund manager or whatever are
behaving entirely rationally to maximize
their own well-being it creates these
systems where markets go bonkers and and
I think the lessons that will probably
come out of that is just leverage is
dangerous but that's that's really
interesting to me another area that
there are some people that just go head
over heels for and I'm interested in it
and I talked about it at the end of the
book is this whole idea that maybe we
can come up with different ways of
modeling market behavior that sort of
take in the fact that investors are
constantly learning but at the same time
that the markets that they're trying to
understand are constantly changing so
it's this constant process of sort of
moving towards getting things right but
then markets continually moving moving
away from that so that there's never any
perfect moment there's never any
equilibrium and there are lots of people
some some of them physicists LMK
economists trying to put up put together
these various they call them adaptive
markets or commanding complexity is
another term of art for this it was all
very fashionable in the early 90s
everybody sort of forgot about it for a
while now it's back I just don't know
where it leads there nobody's come up
gotten any answers out of it yet as to
how markets behave
definitely I mean all these people want
to come by and visit an economics
colonists four times I've been talking
to a lot of these people I mean I guess
there's some potential maybe for
creating these what basically amounts to
securitize lending but in a more
transplant parent straightforward way
but I don't know I at some level I think
we're still figuring out how a financial
system actually works we thought for a
little while that all this stuff had
been solved by basically moving
everything out of institutions like
banks on to markets but it just turn
it's just not that easy I mean markets
debt markets turned out to be incredibly
dependent on the rating agencies to tell
investors what to buy or not and that
that turned out to be I mean they were
worse than banks at determining what's a
good loan what's a bad loan and and so I
don't I just don't know what kind of
institutions are going to exist I mean I
think it's very intoxicating to hear
about a place like Kiva which has all
these people in the US making tiny loans
to somebody starting a bakery in Peru
and it's all very cool although I mean
keep has been so successful in part
because there's no attempt to actually
make a profit off it so maybe it's not a
business model it's just this new model
for organizing charity
children a lot of ways was a pretty
conventional economist he was trained at
MIT in the late 60s and early 70s his
dissertation advisor was Franco
Modigliani who actually co-authored a
couple of papers that sort of led the
way to the rise of rational market
finance and economics so it wasn't like
he was being edited I mean it wasn't
like he was being educated by a bunch of
hippies out in an ashram or something he
was getting a very mathematical
conventional economic education but at
the same time I mean really as I tell it
in the book it this this idea arose kind
of simultaneously and there was a lot of
cross-pollination at MIT in Chicago but
at MIT there was always this sense of
here's this great model for
understanding how the market works and
also we totally agree that the market is
pretty hard to outsmart we don't know
that it's smart but it is hard for other
people to outsmart but we were not so
sure that means that it's all working
perfectly whereas its Chicago it became
this project to sort of show how great
markets were and how much better they
were than any government bureaucrat so
follow along at MIT from the beginning
it was this weird coexistence of these
very rationalist theories of how the
world worked coupled with this kind of
understanding and a lot of classroom
discussion about how the world didn't
work quite the way it was described in
the mathematical models in the classroom
and so you got people coming out of MIT
and Schiller's classmate Robert Merton
Nobel Prize winner very sort of the high
priest for a while of this rationalist
finance was there at the same time and
came out with a very different world
views so Shiller came out with this
conventional training but this sense
that all these theories and models
weren't entirely right and any and he
had a lot of computer skills empirical
skills and so he started during the 70's
to just try to test some of these
theories about market behavior against
the data and initially he was looking at
bond prices and and didn't come up with
anything all that explosive but then
starting to late 70s he started looking
at stock prices and was trying to come
up with a measure of whether they
reflected the fundamental value of the
stocks themselves and so he does
compared stock prices to dip to
subsequent dividend payments and found
that the dividend payments were a lot
less volatile than the stock price
movements and that wasn't proof of
anything a lot of people argued well
companies try to keep their dividends
smooth therefore it shouldn't mean that
much but other people did similar
examinations of earnings comparing them
with stock prices and basically the
lesson was there seemed to be a lot of
unexplained volatility in the stock
market and and later on other people
including some pretty conventional
finance scholars like Richard roll at
UCLA basically confirmed Schiller's
observation and so Shiller then he
actually went and paid paying attention
to real estate for about 10 years but
when he came back to paying attention to
the stock market again in the mid to
late 90s it was just with this idea that
there were these periods when prices
went off in directions that had less to
do with anything going on with the
fundamentals then in just then mood
swings and and so that that sort of led
him by the late 90s to be this really
prominent doubter about the bull market
of those days and then he came out with
I mean it was he totally admit this was
luck but with the most spectacularly
time book of all time in march two
thousand published irrational exuberance
and march two thousand one is exactly
when that exuberance started to tail off
and end
so we wrote irrational exuberance in two
thousand and then he went back to paying
attention to real estate and wrote a new
version the book that came out in 2005
making the point that Wow real estate
prices had gone really crazy by
historical standards and we could
probably expect sometime in the next few
years a collapse in real estate prices
and and so he's now even more of a guru
than ever before because he really did
it some level predict what happened not
not in the details not at the timing but
he at a time when conventional wisdom
was that the real estate market was not
a big danger he was saying it every day
what's interesting about Schiller is his
lesson that he takes from all this is
not that we somehow need to shut down
markets or regulate them vastly more
heavily I mean I think you'd be in favor
of somewhat more regulation but he seems
to think that if only we had even more
financial products if we could all if
we're all buying and selling real estate
derivatives betting that our house
prices might fall then we would have
been better off so in in in it sort of
comes back around to that mit belief in
markets and conventional economics in
the end he so he in any he goes in he's
very often paired with naseem to leb and
options trader turned sort of
bomb-throwing market philosopher and
Shiller comes across as the conservative
or the moderate and all of those
discussions now
I mean his belief is continued growth of
the financial system is a good thing we
just have these shake out swear we
figure out what doesn't work I guess my
one caveat to that because then I after
he said that I went back and was trying
to look at a lot of it because finance
professors always bring this up that
there's a lot of comparative global
research showing the countries with
better developed financial systems do
better than those without them but it's
mostly research about developing
countries and it sort of stands to
reason that a company where nobody has a
country where nobody has a bank account
is not going to progress as fast
economically as one where their banks
and loans available but I don't know
that I think once you get to a well
developed economy with big financial
system I'm sure there's some point of
diminishing returns and it's pretty
clear we reach that in the US over the
past decade where you get a financial
system that sort of takes on a dynamic
of its own and is no longer serving the
economy as a whole but it's just kind of
churning for its own benefit and and and
kind of sucking off lots of money from
the system so and I imagine we will
start getting a lot of research now
about whether there is any way to tell
what what's that point where your
financial system has gotten too big and
i don't think Schiller would disagree
with that he just in the end still
believes in finance and that it can do
good things for people
I i mean i think a lot I and I guess the
difficulty I always have is I have this
impression and you talk to you look at
what's in the textbooks in mba finance
courses that this is being taught
everywhere and that this is sort of
there's this indoctrination going on but
when you start talking to MBA students
especially I mean I've talked to several
at Harvard who are sort of like yeah we
saw that in a class but we never paid
any attention to it um so it it's always
hard to puzzle out the influence of the
ideas that come out of universities on
real life I mean the whole premise of
the book is that they do matter and they
are important but I'm a little hesitant
to claim that that that did everything
but I mean definitely something that
came out of out of business schools and
this change that went on at business
schools starting in the 50s or 60s was
this general idea that just sort of
imparting lessons of how you're supposed
to behave as an executive is not enough
you need this science that explains
what's going on and since economics
could offer a lot of things that looked
like science especially lessons about
how you incentivize people to behave in
certain ways that became really
influential I and I don't know how much
every last mba grad was inculcated with
it but it definitely spread out into the
corporate world and in the 90s and i
write about it it's in some length from
the book this this sense that if only
CEOs were paid in a way that incentivize
them better to want to do do right by
shareholders then this would just be a
better world and that turned out to be i
mean at some level it succeeded in the
early to mid 90s it made corporate
executives a lot more interested in
shareholder value and maximizing stock
price but it also just reached this
point of insanity by the late 90s where
this focus on stock price came to
subsume things that actually create
value for corporations over time
well that I mean that's the puzzle
because one of the stories I tell right
at the end of the book is this young
behavioral finance professor very
critical in his academic work of the
efficient markets Theory tells of
teaching MBA students at Harvard finance
and says that when it comes down to it
he's still closer to believing that the
market is efficient than they are
because they're all these genius mba
students at Harvard who think they're
smarter than any market can be so he
ends up teaching pretty conventional
efficient market stuff to the first two
year students he might then move on
later to more complex things and that's
one of the fascinating things there
isn't any sort of overarching
replacement and and my sense is what
should be taught is there isn't any
overarching model that explains
everything about markets you should look
at several different ones I think that
that's just always a difficult thing for
people to swallow when they've had this
very simple way of teaching how the
world works to suddenly say oh no well
you know you have to use judgment and
there are lots of different ways so my
sense is that there's clearly a lot more
interest among MBA students of other
things besides incentivizing people with
stock options and the like and there's
this whole movement toward reciting
oaths of honor when when people graduate
they just suddenly took off this spring
so at the level of the students there's
interest in other things I think there's
a sense among a lot of the faculty that
maybe they got their focus wrong and
then said it's wrong but I don't and
maybe I'm just not close enough on the
ground to it I don't sense that there's
this whole wholesale replacement about
to happen with some other way of
teaching how markets work
markets financial markets get nutty they
have bubbles they crash that's part of
capitalism it's been there from the very
beginning since finance or capitalism
started and sometimes those bubbles and
crashes are big economic disasters
sometimes they're not and we look back
at them somewhat fondly like the dot-com
bubble and it left some infrastructure
in place it left a lot of people with
skills it's starting companies in place
and it didn't it definitely there was a
hangover but it wasn't an economic
disaster and when you think about it the
the real reason why is because that was
not a bubble built on debt it was a
bubble built on people's expectations
and fantasies of what these companies
would be worth but they were putting
equity into it putting cash into it that
they had no there was no promise that
they'd get it back and so when they
didn't get it back they didn't get it
back when you build a bubble upon debt
like we did with housing it just leads
to this much more difficult situation
where suddenly all these people thought
they'd given money to somebody who is
promising to pay them back and suddenly
huge percentage of those people can't
pay back because their their assets
aren't worth what they paid anywhere
near what they paid for them anymore and
there the economy struggling so it's
some link between debt and and markets
that's the problem so it seems like
going forward the most important thing
is some sort of structure that reduces
leverage especially in boom times
well it's been interesting in this
crisis I mean a lot of people have
looked at it both can't Canada to a
large extent in India to a lesser extent
as countries that basically just kept
their banks from from getting in too
deep in hock and it's hard to identify
why whether there was some structure
that made that happen or just sort of
happen to be the right regulators in
place at the right time because one of
the things that's interesting in the
u.s. there's a lot of talk now all we
need to break down financial
institutions make them smaller so it's
okay if they fail we're but you look at
Canada which has been very successful in
navigating this financial crisis and
there they've got basically like four or
five banks that matter they're all too
big to fail from a Canadian perspective
and yet things worked fine so I I think
I mean I don't know what in a lot of
other areas economically speaking I
would say you know the Scandinavian
countries have this wonderful balance of
providing a safety net but at the same
time understanding that they're
competing in the global economy you have
to have a tax tax system and other
things that are competitive so it at
that level I'd say those are great
examples in terms of financial
regulation I just don't know I mean one
of the things we all all of us all of us
pundits in the u.s. complain about is
how we've got a zillion different
banking regulatory agencies and that
they're all sometimes at cross purposes
and things fall between the cracks but
then I mean the UK has a unitary
regulator that's in charge of every
aspect of the financial system and there
the other country that did the worst in
this crisis along with us so there there
isn't I don't see any obvious model
other than just people doing their job
better as they did in a few countries
like Canada and India
a lot of people say that but we seem to
be moving in a direction of having a
smaller group of even bigger banks
dominating our financial system and
maybe a couple years down the road that
will start to change and they'll decide
that it's too unwieldy to have bank
america and Merrill Lynch together and
start breaking up and that would partly
solve the problem but I mean I think
part of it has been this remembering a
lesson that was learned in the 30s and
has since been forgotten which is that
if you want to have a banking system
that doesn't collapse every few years
you need to have a government role in it
and I mean people who sort of look
nostalgic Lee back to the 19th century
where there were rashes of bank failures
all the time I mean the flip side of
that is you had far less finance you had
a much less developed financial system
it was much harder to get financing to
start companies to buy houses to do
whatever else so if so you could have
that kind of system where everybody's
just used to failure every few years but
then that's a much you probably have a
smaller economy much less lending
overall so I think there's been this
understanding by a lot of kind of
interesting people on the conservative
side Richard Posner the federal judge in
Chicago Law Professor is the most
obvious example we sort of realized that
actually there's a reason for bank
regulation there's a reason why we have
it there's a reason why we keep banks
from taking certain risks so I think
that's just back and people understand
that and what we got to see going
forward because what happened basically
over the past 20 years is that banks per
se were still restricted from taking
risk but all of these other financial
institutions and then increasingly after
the glass well even before
glass-steagall was repealed in 1999
subsidiaries of bank holding companies
were allowed to engage in all these
really risky behaviors and I think now
there's this understanding that okay all
this stuff all these other people were
doing is if it involves lending it's
basically banking and it should probably
be subject to the same set of rules that
we had before so I guess the big
difference is there's been this
reaffirmation that there's a
reason for banking regulation and
there's been this realization that all
these things that didn't call themselves
banks actually were banks and are
subject to the same risks of runs that
banks were and therefore we need to
think differently about how to regulate
them